archiv sigue bajo el asedio ruso
pero los residentes de esta ciudad
ucraniana aunque desolados quieren
reconstruirla
especialmente esta escuela para que los
niños regresen a clases todos los
estudiantes viven cerca hoy vimos una
fuerte explosión por la noche sin
llamadas ni clamores todos se reunieron
aquí después de todas las clases que se
quedaron en kharkiv están ayudando a
retirar los escombros ya restaurar la
escuela es como boston la directora cree
que podrán reabrir pronto estamos
limpiando nos prepararemos para reabrir
el 1 de septiembre y dejar que los niños
vayan a la escuela primaria cerca otra
escuela también fue bombardeada el
ataque provocó un incendio en un mercado
alcanzó un almacén de alimentos y ayuda
humanitaria y dos escuelas de carrera
creo que hubo varios cohetes o misiles
grad con un punto y luego se desató el
fuego eso es todo parece que han
extinguido el fuego no creo que hubiera
gente dentro del mercado estaba cerrado
según las autoridades ucranianas unas
500 personas han perdido la vida en esta
ciudad desde el comienzo de la invasión
rusa el 24 de febrero
más de 600 edificios entre hospitales
clínicas y escuelas han sido destruidos
el gobierno de vladímir putin niega que
haya alcanzado a civiles en sus ataques